3 4 rapports ce matin en commission
et à suivre on a les examens des
amendements sur le projet de loi pleine
emploi
ce qui fait que nos collègues
n'a pas arrêté depuis 8h30 ce matin
côté on va commencer
on va commencer ça va les faire venir
oui non mais
donc en fait merci d'être venu pour
cette audition
qu'on souhaitait faire depuis un moment
sur cette prise en charge de la douleur
il y avait eu il y avait eu cette
un petit déjeuner qui avait été organisé
par la flare que l'association française
de lutte contre les ça fait les
affections
rhumatologiques donc il y avait eu cette
table ronde qui avait lieu il y a
quelques mois de la flamme à laquelle
vous aviez participé et qu'elle avait
participé d'ailleurs la ministre Agnès
Firma le Baudot
moi j'avais été sollicité également dans
le cadre de mon département de ma région
je me souviens plus sur la notion de de
plan douleur
des
comment s'appelle des centres
spécifiques de traitement de la douleur
et j'avais rencontré Marc l'évêque
spécialiste de la douleur aussi à un
tableau une intervention que l'on avait
fait ensemble sur à l'Institut sapiens
sur justement la douleur avec avec ce
volet
crise des
opioïdes aux États-Unis comment on
prenait en charge la douleur il y
aura-t-il un nouveau plan douleur
c'était un peu ce que demandait les à la
fois les patients et les associations ou
les associations de patients mais aussi
certains professionnels de santé et
commence avec la Haute Autorité de santé
que vous représentez docteur Valéry RTL
devait rendre ses conclusions au mois de
mars sur justement cette notion de
douleur on a attendu que le rapport de
la chaise soit rendu pour pouvoir vous
entendre le présenter à la commission au
commissaire à nos administrateurs qui
suivent ces dossiers et
et avec les retraites tout ça on a un
peu décalé on a réussi quand même à
trouver une date et c'est celle
d'aujourd'hui
donc on a vu en plus puisque ce matin on
rendait le rapport sur la fin de vie
combien la question de la douleur des
soins palliatifs aussi étaient
importantes
on sait aussi qu'il y a des débats sur
l'utilisation des dérivés du cannabis
je sais Marc le fait que vous êtes
exprimé là-dessus aussi donc il y a pas
mal de sujets autour de la douleur qui
nous sommes importants et d'avoir votre
éclairage à tous les trois
et importants
donc
ce que je vous propose c'est les uns
après les autres commencera peut-être
par la chaise avec le docteur Vallery
Ertel pooke
responsable de l'arme des bonnes
pratiques à la direction de
l'amélioration de la qualité de la
sécurité des soins sur sur ce que sont
les conclusions de la Haute Autorité de
Santé sur ce sujet il y aura-t-il un
nouveau plan en douleur ou pas et puis
et puis ensuite
soit Marc levex sur le professeur
Valeria Martinez qui représente la
société française d'études et traitement
de la douleur que vous nous fassiez par
vos observations
de vos réflexions sur ce sujet important
et ensuite on échangera avec les
commissaires ça vous va
donc qui commence alors docteur vous y
allez peut-être la HS qu'on fasse le
point c'est en fait on attendait le
rapport de la SAS pour lancer cette
table ronde alors l'audition fait
l'objet d'une rotation vidéo qui sera
disponible à la demande et que
retransmis sur le site du Sénat
bonjour à toutes et à tous madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs je
voudrais commencer par quelques éléments
là c'est bien d'accord très bien
quelques éléments de contexte en France
la douleur tout type confondu et la
première est l'une des premières causes
de consultation en médecine générale et
en service d'accueil des urgences
il existe plusieurs types de douleurs
dans lequel je vais pas rentrer je
laisserai les professionnels de santé de
terrain
rentrer dans les détails de la douleur
s'ils veulent par contre il existe
plusieurs types aigus subaigu chroniques
et là ce dont je vais vous parler c'est
les travaux de la Haute Autorité de
Santé publié en février 2023 qui
s'intéresse au parcours de santé de la
personne
ayant une douleur chronique
la douleur chronique est définie comme
une douleur qui persiste tout se
reproduit pendant plus de trois mois
en 2004 quelques éléments de prévalence
une étude à évaluer la prévalence des
douleurs chroniques d'intensité modérée
à sévère chez les adultes de 18 ans et
plus à à peu près 20% ce qui pourrait
représenter 12 millions de personnes de
18 ans et plus
quelques éléments de constat si les
trois plans nationaux de lutte contre la
douleur donc qui ont eu lieu de 98 à
2010 ont permis de progresser sur la
prise en charge de la douleur notamment
par les créations des 250 structures
douleurs chroniques à peu près
la prise en charge de la douleur
chronique et de la formation des
professionnels de santé
sont encore à améliorer il y a encore
des marges de progrès
surtout qu'on sait que plus la prise en
charge est tardive sur ses patients plus
la situation va être complexe et les
possibilités d'amélioration plus
limitées
on sait également que les personnes
présentant des douleurs chroniques sont
orientés tardivement vers les structures
spécialisées et les structures douleurs
chroniques après une errance
diagnostic et thérapeutique en moyenne
c'est des moyennes de 5 ans et
lorsqu'elles sont adressées aux
structures douleurs chroniques elles
doivent en plus attendre un délai
d'attente qui est variable hétérogène
d'une région à l'autre et environ 8 mois
et une fois que cette évaluation est
réalisée par la structure par les
structures douleurs chroniques et si
selon les besoins des patients une prise
en charge est initié les relais avec les
professionnels de ville ne sont pas
suffisamment structurés et enfin à ce
constat il y avait il y a évidemment
malheureusement des inégalités
territoriales d'accès aux soins
spécialisés qui persistent notamment
pour l'accès aux différentes techniques
disponibles pour la prise en charge de
ces patients variables suivant les
structures spécialisées des territoires
c'est dans ce contexte que la Haute
Autorité de santé à la demande du
ministère à travailler sur la définition
d'un parcours de santé des patients
douloureux chroniques et qui répondent à
des standards de qualité conformes aux
recommandations
internationales notamment les
professionnels que sont Marc l'évêque et
Madame Martinez pourront dire qu'il faut
c'est un modèle psy biopsychosocial
c'est une prise en charge dans une
équipe pluridisciplinaire et
pluriprofessionnelle parce que c'est des
patients qui sont chroniques et ils le
diront mieux que moi mais ce qui est
important c'est le modèle psychosocial
et la prise en charge
pluriprofessionnelle
la chaise donc a défini un parcours
gradué en trois niveaux
en réponse à la complexité du profil du
patient donc ce parcours hiérarchisé en
trois niveaux un niveau 1 qui repose sur
le premier recours laissons un primaires
notamment la médecine de ville et les
médecins traitants l'équipe de soins
primaire et les médecins spécialistes de
ville
l'équipe de soins primaires en soins de
ville idéal elle est composée du médecin
traitant d'un infirmier enfin
pluriprofessionnel kinésithérapeute
pharmacien et psychologue le niveau 2
est constitué par les structures
douleurs chroniques et par les services
hospitaliers de spécialité et le niveau
3 est défini par les centres
d'évaluation et traitements de la
douleur ça c'est les trois niveaux tels
que définis dans le parcours de la HS
bien sûr le parcours s'appuie sur les
structeurs douleurs chroniques les plus
de 250 mais également sur
les l'exercice coordonné des soins de
ville donc tout ce qui est alors je vais
éviter les sigles les communautés
professionnelles territoriales de santé
donc CPTs je l'ai dit quand même maison
de santé pluriprofessionnelle donc tout
ce qui est MSP centre de santé donc
c'est déesse et équipe de soins
primaires
ce parcours repose également sur les
nouvelles technologies et le numérique
en santé donc tout ce qui est le
développement de la télé santé et des
nouvelles technologies et également et
ça c'est très important pour la Haute
Autorité de Santé sur les nouveaux
métiers donc tout ce qui est infirmier
de pratique avancée et
infirmier à compétences élargie tel que
définie dans des protocoles de
coopération donc c'est les quatre les
quatre éléments sur lesquels ce parcours
s'appuie
autre innovation ce parcours propose la
mise en place de services
proposés donc au niveau de l'interface
ville hôpital donc ces services seraient
proposés par la structure douleur
chronique de proximité sur le territoire
et à destination des professionnels de
ville de son territoire notamment les
médecins traitants et ses services
comprendraient ce que je dis
comprendrait puisque c'est il faut
mettre en place le parcours de santé
donc les services c'est une autre lame
dédiée au médecin traitant pour avoir
accès notamment à des téléspertises donc
le service est également de la
télémédecine de la télé-expertise de la
téléconsultation
les services sera également des outils
de partage des informations
pour échanger les données entre
professionnels de santé pour un exercice
coordonné c'est primordial et
cette
interface pourrait aussi délivrer des
formations enfin en tout cas la
structure tout leur chronique de
proximité pour aider livrer des
formations à destination des médecins
traitant de ville qui quand on les
interroge se sentent quand même un peu
démuni d'un point de vue de la formation
qu'ils ont eu initiales et puis
évidemment la formation continue donc
c'est un élément important la formation
des professionnels de santé en
complément de ces guides la HS a produit
également des outils pour ces
professionnels de soins primaires que
sont Ingrid d'évaluation
d'un patient douloureux chronique parce
qu'en fait on a on a eu besoin comme il
y a 12 millions de personnes tout le
monde peut-être je ne l'ai pas assez dit
ne peut pas aller accéder à une
structure douleur chronique surtout que
il ne nécessite pas forcément des des
soins par le niveau 3 en fait ou le
niveau 2 donc il faut aider et outiller
les professionnels de santé de niveau 1
en premier le médecin généraliste et
donc on a fait une grille en
collaboration avec les professionnels
bien sûr une grille de premier
évaluation d'un patient douloureux
chronique un auto questionnaire pour la
personne
atteinte de douleurs chroniques et un
formulaire d'adressage pour aider à
recueillir les éléments importants en
soins primaire qui doit être transmis
aux structures spécialisées
et enfin en complément de ce travail
enfin en complément de ces travaux de la
Haute Autorité de Santé toujours en
partenariat avec les professionnels que
sont les médecins généralistes et
les membres de la Société française de
la sfedd
on va décliner des fiches par population
spécifique donc des fiches de
déclinaison de ce parcours en trois
niveaux dans des populations spécifiques
qui nécessitent
comment dire de faire des des fiches
plus orientées donc il y aura des
enfants une fiche sur les enfants et les
adolescents une fille sur la douleur
chronique en cancérologie qui nécessite
des traitements et des structures un peu
différentes et tout ce qui est regroupé
dans les personnes vulnérables et qui
peuvent pas se rendre forcément dans un
lieu de soins et qui nécessite une prise
en charge et également seront déclinés
dans un deuxième temps mais les
thématiques n'ont pas encore été défini
avec les professionnels des thématiques
par type de douleurs chroniques et là
peut-être que Valérian Martinez pourra
compléter mes propos sur les thématiques
qui seront choisies donc on va décliner
ce parcours qui est assez générique en
typologie de douleurs chroniques donc
notamment la neuropathie les douleurs
neuropathiques mais pas que selon la
définition qui auront été faites par les
professionnels de terrain voilà
Martinez ensuite Marc l'évêque
cette présentation et on aura sûrement
des échanges et des questions très bien
donc j'ai quelques propos préliminaires
donc bonjour à tous même la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les parlementaires
tout d'abord je tiens à remercier je
vous tiens à remercier de pour votre
engagement le suivi de ce dossier
puisque depuis notre rencontre en
dernier en octobre dernier le jour
mondial de la douleur vous avez donc
organisé cette journée et donc la
publication des recommandations de la
chasse sur le parcours des soins des
patients de l'euro chronique en début
d'année constituerait une vraie
opportunité de se poser la question de
quelle est la problématique de ces
passions douloureux chroniques en France
donc c'est recommandations en
partenariat avec le collège des médecins
généralistes et la chas on contribue à
mettre l'accent comme la présenter
précédemment au docteur Paul Airtel de
la chaise sur trois points importants
qui sont nouveaux le renforcement de
l'articulation ville hôpital en
positionnant le médecin généraliste
comme un acteur principal de
coordination des soins de l'outillage du
premier recours pour la prévention
l'évaluation et la prise en charge de la
douleur chronique et troisièmement le
développement de l'usage de la télé
santé dans le parcours de soins alors
bien évidemment bien évidemment que tous
ces éléments peuvent fonctionner comme
il a été précisé dans le texte même des
recommandations avec des moyens des
moyens financiers et humains pour mettre
en œuvre ce parcours de soins il faut
également une formation initiale et
continue en douleur de tous les
soignants de qualité et consolider
consolider le monde de la douleur c'est
à dire en particulier les structures de
la douleur sur lequel il faudra
s'appuyer et il faut reconnaître et
valoriser leur expertise donc je
souhaite dans ces propos préliminaires
appelés un petit peu des points
importants sur ce qu'est la douleur
chronique donc elle affecte en effet 12
millions de nos concitoyens et peut
toucher n'importe qui à n'importe quel
âge de la vie ça peut être nos enfants
ça peut être notre parent la douleur
chronique affecte non seulement la santé
physique mais aussi le bien-être
émotionnel les relations
interpersonnelles la capacité qui a
travaillé elle peut entraîner une
détresse psychologique une dépression
une anxiété une diminution de la qualité
de vie globale donc c'est pour ça que la
douleur chronique est une véritable
maladie elle va s'installer de façon
insidieuse être débute souvent par une
douleur aiguë à la chute d'un
traumatisme de la vie une maladie ou une
vulnérabilité physique ou psychique mal
prise en charge et elle prend de la
place beaucoup de place de plus en plus
elle se répercute sur le sommeil
l'humeur la vie professionnelle et
familiale elle pèse énormément sur la
société entière et puis d'ailleurs il
faut savoir que depuis 2019 la douleur
chronique sont classées comme une
maladie à part entière par
l'Organisation mondiale de la santé
alors oui la douleur chronique est une
maladie apparentière au même titre que
la dépression ou les maladies
cardiovasculaires elle entraîne
d'importants coûts économiques pour la
société notamment en termes de dépenses
liées aux consultation médicale au
traitement aux arrêts de travail liés à
la douleur chronique à son
retentissement
de plus la douleur chronique peut être
coûteuse en raison de l'errance médicale
et des effets néfastes des traitements
inappropriés en effet la douleur
chronique en tant que maladie est encore
largement sous diagnostiqué et
insuffisamment prise en charge par notre
système de santé donc il est essentiel
de prendre en compte l'impact sociétal
de la douleur chronique lors de
l'élaboration de politique de santé
il faut savoir que depuis plusieurs
années la SFE TD donc la société
française d'études et traitements de la
douleur que je préside aujourd'hui et je
porte la voix porte au niveau des
pouvoirs publics la problématique de la
douleur chronique et de son impact
sociétal nous sommes force de
proposition d'un programme douleur
reposant sur trois axes formation
parcours de soins et public vulnérables
sont visés dans ce programme et nous
déclinons à travers de 10 propositions
élaborées avec plusieurs autres sociétés
savantes et des associations de patients
le 3 avril dernier lors de la clôture de
la convention citoyenne sur la fin de
vie le président de la République a
annoncé le plan décennale national de
prise en charge de la douleur et des
soins palliatifs
c'est avec une grande satisfaction que
la FFE TD accueilli cette nouvelle après
plus de 10 ans d'attente depuis le
quatrième plan douleur qui n'a jamais vu
le jour depuis 2012 il faut savoir que
depuis 2012 il n'y a pas eu de plan
douleur les mots de prise en charge de
la douleur ont été prononcées par notre
président
nous nous réjouissons de constater que
la douleur retrouve enfin sa place dans
l'agenda politique
mais après la première voie première
vague de joie suscité par l'annonce de
ce plan des Sénats les naturels de se
poser des questions sur le périmètre
d'action de ce plan et dans quelle
mesure il déclinera des solutions
concrètes aux concitoyens souffrant de
douleurs chroniques tout au long de leur
existence puisque douleur chronique et
soins palliatifs ce n'est pas tout à
fait la même chose
la SF fut des tiens souligné et à
rappeler que la douleur chronique est
une entité distincte qui mérite d'être
considérée indépendamment sans
distinction d'âge de situations de la
personne concernée la douleur chronique
ne peut être réduite à un simple
symptômes mais doit être appréhendé dans
sa globalité elle est une maladie
chronique à part entière qui nécessite
une prise en charge complète incluant la
prévention l'accompagnement et le
soulagement de tout au long de la vie la
SCPT engage à porter son expertise et à
collaborer activement avec des décideurs
politiques et les acteurs de santé pour
garantir que la prise en charge de la
douleur dans le plan décennale afin
qu'il réponde au mieux aux besoins de
nos concitoyens
le plan décennal proposé par notre
gouvernement extracteur de trois axes
son palliatifs la gestion de la douleur
et la fin de vie
bien entendu ce plan décennal offre une
opportunité de développer des synergies
avec des soins palliatifs nous
identifions plusieurs points communs
dans la prise en charge de la douleur ou
les patients en difficulté pourraient
bénéficier de nos expertises alors
qu'elle pourrait être ces mesures
quelles seront les actions prioritaires
tout d'abord répondre aux besoins urgent
d'accès à certaines thérapeutiques en
mettant en place des actions dont les
résultats pour être mesurés rapidement
par exemple le développement de
techniques qu'on appelle
neuro-modulation qui consiste à diminuer
ou à interrompre le message douloureux
en particulier des techniques comme
l'analgésie intrathécale qui sont très
peu accessibles dans notre pays cette
méthode consiste en fait administrer des
médicaments auprès de la moelle avec un
petit cathéter et interrompre le message
douloureux et il indiqué dans certains
douleurs réfractaires notamment quand
c'est en logique comme cancer du
pancréas elle vient abdomen n'est pas
seulement et savez-vous quels sont les
chances de bénéficier de cette technique
aujourd'hui si vous êtes atteint de
telles douleurs
une dizaine ici en fait si vous êtes une
dizaine un sur 10 pour pouvoir
bénéficier de cette technique disons que
dans cette assemblée seulement une
personne pourra bénéficier de cette
technique si vous et peut-être pas du
tout si vous avez dans certaines régions
parler de région tout à l'heure mais
voilà dans certaines régions vous ne
pourrez pas bénéficier ces techniques
cet exemple mais je pourrais en citer
d'autres illustre les efforts à faire
ces prochaines années le manque de
médecin formé à ces techniques le manque
de connaissances sur ces techniques et
sur son utilité la besoin d'organiser
des réseaux pour organiser l'adressage
de ses patients et le suivi de ses
patients mais également pour implémenter
et valoriser il faut valoriser
financièrement l'acte et le suivi de ses
patients
deuxième piste qui pourrait développer
dans ce plan décennale c'est développer
des actions sur le dépistage des
patients à risque en douleur chronique
notre ministre de la Santé François
Brown entend faire de la prévention un
pilier de la politique de santé il faut
savoir que les avancées dans le domaine
du traitement de la dans le cancer ont
été indéniablement améliorés et le taux
de guérison et de rémission pour de
nombreux types de cancers est important
cependant il est important de
reconnaître que certains traitements
tels que la chirurgie la chimiothérapie
la radiothérapie peuvent laisser des
séquelles douloureuses notamment lésant
les petites fibres neuves ça donne des
douleurs neuropathiques qui sont les
douleurs les plus intenses les plus
difficiles à traiter
ce type de douleur compromet
considérablement la qualité vie des
patients toute la vie restante même si
le cancer lui-même n'est plus
d'actualité et donc il y a encore
beaucoup à faire en termes de dépistage
de ces douleurs de prise en charge
rapide et de l'accès aux soins approprié
pour ses patients sur l'ensemble du
territoire français puisqu'en fait trop
vraiment trop de patience on tolérance
et diagnostic et thérapeutiques pour des
douleurs déclenchées par les soins cette
réalité doit être entendue et adressée
de manière efficace la prévention de la
douleur coûte beaucoup moins cher que la
prise en charge d'une douleur chronique
qui est installée
troisième volet la SFE TD des plaides
pour en faire de la douleur une
spécialité médicale il faut savoir que
la formation des médecins des médecins
de demain est un sujet essentiel de la
société française est une traitement la
douleur elle plaide en faveur de la
reconnaissance de la douleur et des
soins palliatifs comme une spécialité
médicale à part entière les résultats de
notre enquête démographique qu'on a fait
l'an dernier et ont été ont publié mais
en évidence un problème préoccupant une
pénurie éminente de médecins spécialisés
en douleur de la prise en charge de
l'heure selon les chiffres marquants de
cette enquête incarnent les effectifs
vont partir à la retraite d'ici 5 ans et
il n'est pas certain qu'ils soient tous
remplacés par les nouveaux praticiens
formés
faut savoir qu'actuellement des
structures de prise en charge de la
douleur ne peuvent couvrir environ que
1,5% de la population souffrant de
douleurs chroniques alors que près de 5%
de cette population de leur chronique
sont des cas complexes et qui pourraient
bénéficier de l'expertise et des
techniques spécifiques offertes par les
unités spécialisées de la douleur
ces constats mettent en évidence
l'urgence l'urgence de mettre prendre
des mesures concrètes pour former rendre
attractif et pérenniser les structures
douleurs le problème est identique dans
le domaine des soins palliatifs ou le
nombre de médecins est insuffisant pour
répondre aux besoins croissants et face
à cette problématique commune aux soins
palliatifs à la prise en charge de la
douleur chronique il est nécessaire de
réfléchir à l'opportunité d'en faire des
spécialités à part entière dans le cadre
de ce plan décennale une telle
initiative permettrait d'agir sur le
long terme de garantir une amélioration
durable de la prise en charge de la
douleur et des soins palliatifs en
France pour les générations futures elle
résoudrait les problèmes de régulation
de flux d'attractivité et de
pérennisation des structures
spécialisées et ne pas prendre le temps
de réfléchir à cette question de la
spécialisation de la médecine de la
douleur et des soins palliatifs à
l'occasion de ce plan décennale serait
une erreur
et bien je suis un autre sujet parallèle
à la formation des médecins c'est bien
sûr c'est la reconnaissance en pratique
avancée des infirmières ressources
douleurs qui nous accompagnent tous les
jours alors Mesdames et Messieurs les
parlementaires en présentant ces propos
préliminaires mon attention est de
mettre en évidence des sujets qui nous
préoccupent et j'espère que la
discussion les échange pourront vous
éclairer au mieux sur ces sujets merci
merci docteur Marc l'éveil
oui bonjour madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
voilà quelques mots pour me présenter là
j'étais formé en Belgique au Canada et
en Belgique j'exerce la neurochirurgie
de la logologie libérale à Marseille
après avoir été praticien à la
Pitié-Salpêtrière et la Timone
voilà pour nous médecin de la douleur
c'est un grand soulagement que la
commission des affaires sociales doit se
saisisse de ce sujet de la douleur
chronique et je vous remercie et ça pour
deux raisons déjà c'est un drame
individuel
on l'a dit un fléau national un patient
sur 5 un adulte sur 5 est touché si
c'est pas votre sœur c'est votre frère
si c'est pas votre frère c'est votre
grand-mère et puis une prise en charge
qu'il faut bien dire aujourd'hui
insuffisante alors ça disait la douleur
c'est le c'est le vide et elle se
rappelle à nous à chaque instant la
douleur elle est elle est usante c'est
une torture qui nous isole et cet
isolement
contribue à la chronicisation la le
conjoint finit par se lasser voir par se
casser l'employeur aussi et donc c'est
la lente spirale biopsychosociale là
qu'on a évoqué donc au plan économique
on l'a dit
en chiffres c'est
80 millions de journées de travail qui
qui s'en trouvent affectés soit un
préjudice au bas mot de 1 milliard 200
millions par an
et il faut pas oublier qu'en fait les
médicaments
notamment antalgiques en particulier
antalgique participe de cette absente
parce que lorsque vous pouvez plus
conduire votre véhicule vous pouvez plus
aller au travail et
il faut bien dire aujourd'hui que les
morts finis que sont prescrits en
première ligne et pas seulement les
morphiniques les psychotropes parce que
bien souvent les médecins qui sont en
première ligne les médecins généralistes
sont démunis face à des patients
douloureux chroniques qui ne trouvent
pas de déboucher dans les centres de la
douleur chronique avec seulement 3% des
patients douloureux chroniques qui
peuvent trouver une place dans ces
centres de la douleur chronique qui sont
sur saturés avec des médicaments dont
l'efficacité aujourd'hui l'inefficacité
je devrais dire et de mieux en mieux
documenter alors j'avais quelques petits
diapo là pour vous montrer
là les principales classes de
médicaments qu'on utilise dans la
douleur neuropathique
le NNT c'est le nombre de patients qui
le font pour que un seul soit
soulagé de 30 à 50%. donc là je vous
laisse voir les chiffres en fait pour
les principales classes médicamenteuses
qu'on utilise dans la douleur
neuropathique il faut entre 5 6 voir 8
voire plus patient pour qu'un seul soit
soulagé
c'est une chose d'autre part
j'ai pris l'exemple d'un médicament qui
est très utilisé qui est la prégabaline
qu'un entier épileptique qu'on utilise
dans la douleur neuropathique qui a été
extrêmement prescrit ça c'est un article
d'une nuit gland qui marche qui montre
que
cette molécule versus placée beau dans
la sciatique chronique ou la sciatique
aiguë il y a pas de différence la seule
différence que l'on observe c'est au
niveau des effets indésirables
donc pourquoi pourquoi ce recours en
fait à l'entalgie chimique de façon
systématique alors on l'a dit déjà par
manque de formation il y a à peu près
une 30 à 40 heures dans notre cursus qui
est alloué à la douleur chronique alors
qu'on sait que c'est la première raison
de consultation chez le médecin traitant
et souvent en fait on imagine que la
douleur chronique c'est finalement un
continuum de la douleur aiguë alors que
c'est pas du tout finalement la même
physiopathologie c'est pas les mêmes
traitements
donc 3% seulement des patients qui qui
accèdent à ces centres de la douleur et
70% c'est c'est le Livre blanc de la sf
E te dit en 2017 qui disait 70% des
patients qui n'étaient pas satisfaits de
leur prise en charge
donc il faut ajouter que cette
prescription
médicamenteuse forte
elle est à l'intervient dans un contexte
de malaise social de précarité de
problèmes familiaux de difficulté au
travail je dirais même aussi de vie
d'existentielle qui se traduisent dans
le corps par des dombasgies par des
céphalées de tension
ou toutes ces autres douleurs que l'on
appelle fonctionnelles
et les États-Unis en sont la tragique
illustration la crise des opioïdes qui
ravage le pays 500 000 morts un
cimetière de 500.000 tombes dont les
tombes les plus connus sont celles de
Michael Jackson et de Prince
ça a débuté dans les États les plus
touchés par la crise économique la
fameuse belt la ceinture de rouille et
il y a un article qui est très
intéressant là que je me suis permis de
vous montrer qui qui nous montre la
superposition du vote Trump et les morts
par au puits
ça souligne le lien en fait toutes ces
gueules cassées de la mondialisation ça
souligne le lien entre entre souffrance
et des classements et des classements
social alors bon dans mon dernier
bouquin avec un peu de provocation je me
suis permis de vous le vous le donner il
y a un chapitre que j'inticule lunette
rose pour gilet jaune pour finalement
décrire les risques d'une médicalisation
de la précarité et du déclassement
notamment par la prescription des morts
finis et des psychotropes
alors le danger quand on n'a pas accès à
une offre compétente et dimensionnée de
médecine de la douleur c'est de
confondre
douleur physique et détresse
psychologiques
et de réduire la prise en charge aux
médicaments qui souvent est la réponse
la plus la plus facile et la plus
fréquente ne serait-ce que par l'accès
d'une part au pharmacie 21.000 femmes
21000 officines et moins de 300 centres
de la douleur chronique sachant que
c'est 100 de la douleur chronique sont
les seules portes d'entrée aux
alternatives non médicamenteuses
Martinez notre présidente a parlé de la
neuro modulation qui est une véritable
révolution dans la prise en charge de la
douleur et bien on y accède que par les
centres de la douleur
et rappelons que pour le médecin
généraliste qui est en première ligne le
réflexe le plus facile
pour lui comme pour le patient c'est
cette sortir quand il a une
consultation à 26,50 €
c'est de sortir l'ordonnancier prescrit
le tramadol éventuellement une radio et
bien souvent
on trouvera des anomalies à la radio
rachis dégénératif et ça ça va alimenter
la machine à examen clinique alors que
si il avait le temps de questionner sur
le moral comment ça va le petit comment
ça va la famille est-ce que le boulot
vous plaît etc bon des consignations qui
prennent beaucoup plus de temps on
s'apercevrait qu'il y a pas mal au dos
mais qu'il en a plein plein le dos
donc voilà pour le patient c'est aussi
une une réponse magique qui ne
questionne pas son son mode de vie
voilà à cela s'ajoute la sédentarité le
surpoids j'avais évoqué les 4S qui
sifflent sur nos sociétés la solitude
qui est pourvoyeuse de dépression qui
est pourvoyeuse de souffrance bon le
seul S qui vaille c'est la sénescence
parce qu'il est quand même bon signe de
vieillir même si à partir de 70 ans il y
a un patient une personne sur deux qui
est qui est douloureuse chronique
voilà alors quels sont les les solutions
face à ce drame ce fléau sociétal alors
Valéria Martinez là les a les a évoqué
moi il y a un point que je voudrais
rajouter
et c'est normal parce que la sfet dit
représente en grande majorité les les
psychologues les médecins et les
infirmiers du public parce
qu'aujourd'hui la médecine de la douleur
en grande majorité elle est représentée
par l'hôpital public et c'est à mon sens
là un des soucis parce que c'est un
petit peu comme si vous pouviez accéder
à votre médecin généraliste que par les
urgences c'est à dire que par les
centres hospitaliers donc c'est on est
en algologie une vision extrêmement
hospitalo centrée
alors à titre d'exemple 60% de la
chirurgie aujourd'hui se fait dans notre
pays en libéral alors que c'est la prise
en charge d'ailleurs je crois qu'on a
pas tellement de chiffres pour ainsi
dire on doit être moins d'une centaine à
mon sens d'algologues libéral dans notre
dans notre pays alors pourquoi cette
offre anémique alors avant tout un c'est
la souvalia la sous-valorisation
pardonnez-moi de cette activité qui va
conduire à l'extinction de cette
médecine avant même qu'elle se soit
développée et qu'elle puisse un petit
peu apporter son qu'elle puisse voler au
secours de la de la médecine de la de la
douleur publique alors pourquoi en fait
c'est mal valorisé parce que c'est des
consultations qui sont longues qui sont
complexes souvent les patients il nous
arrive avec des sacs de de supermarché
voire parfois même des valises à
roulettes
donc c'est des consultations qui sont
valorisées 23 euros
en secteur 2 30 euros en sectera sachant
qu'on n'a pas le droit à la PC c'est à
dire la consultation à 45 euros qui est
[Musique]
que les chirurgiens les anesthésistes
peuvent avoir ensuite les actes sont
dévalorisés je vais prendre l'exemple de
la stimulation médullaire c'est mon
c'est mon job
c'est une des techniques les plus
efficaces aujourd'hui contre la douleur
chronique c'est à peu près impatient sur
deux qui est soulagé contrairement aux
médicaments que l'on voyait tout à
l'heure bon c'est coté 168 euros c'est à
peu près deux heures d'intervention là
dessus on reverse 6% à la clinique il
faut payer l'aide d'opératoire les
assurances en neurochirurgie en esthésie
parmi les plus chers aujourd'hui
pour comparaison une chirurgie de la
cataracte
ça a moins de 10 minutes c'est 270 euros
pour le chirurgien et 110 euros pour
l'anesthésiste
donc ça conduit nos concitoyens à un
moindre accès à ces techniques Immo
innovantes et
c'est inférieur à la moyenne européenne
pondérée moi je prendrai l'exemple de la
Belgique puisqu'ils j'ai exercé en
Belgique c'est 119 patients sur un
million qui ont accès tandis que dans
notre pays il y a 39 patients sur un
million qui ont accès à la stimulation
médullaire c'est à 3 à 4 fois moins
il y a aussi le risque de désengagement
de ces techniques innovantes notamment
par les industriels à un moment donné où
ces techniques exposent le téléphone que
vous avez dans votre poche en fait il
traduit bien cette évolution fulgurante
qui a eu en 30 ans et là on voit sur le
petit bonhomme là toutes les cibles
aujourd'hui qui s'offrent à la
neuromodulation que ce soit en surface
de la peau au niveau des nerfs au niveau
du ganglion dorsal de la moelle épinière
la stimulation médullaire la stimulation
profonde qui reste du domaine de la
recherche clinique la stimulation
corticale et la stimulation antique
transcrânienne qui est une technique
qui a très peu décédé indésirables et
qui est très efficace en cas d'échec
médicamenteux
alors Valeria l'a évoqué le cas du
problème de l'intrathécale que qui n'est
pas sur le qui est une technique très
efficace qui permet de réduire par 300
la dose de morphine c'est à dire que le
la morphine ne circule plus dans le
patient cancéreux notamment qui a en fin
de vie et ça lui permet de conserver une
vie de relation dans ces derniers jours
qui sont qui sont si précieux et bien le
remplissage de ces pompes c'est 28 euros
alors que une PC la programmation d'une
pompe à morphine externe c'est 88 euros
bon c'est des détails techniques mais ça
montre un petit peu aujourd'hui les les
aberrations de notre codification donc
voilà sans parler des actes qui sont
absolument pas valorisés on parle de la
tens qui n'est pas valorisée l'hypnose
ça n'est pas non plus et puis le plus
choquant aujourd'hui la stimulation
magnétique transcraienne dont j'ai dont
j'ai parlé qui permet de soulager
environ un patient sur deux qu'on
utilise également dans la dépression
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas d'acte donc on
fait des codages par assimilation et
donc les confrères les uns après les
autres se font allumer parce que ils
sont dans l'illégalité or c'est ces
techniques aujourd'hui sont reconnues
sont même prôner par les sociétés
savantes et comme derrière il y a pas de
codage il y a pas de modèle il n'y a pas
de modèle économique donc les centres
publics et privés rechignent à faire
l'acquisition de ces matériels coûteux
entre 100 et 200000 euros qui pourtant
sont dénuées des faits indésirables
contrairement aux médicaments que j'ai
évoqué
alors
j'avais
pris l'exemple des douleurs
neuropathiques les douleurs
neuropathiques c'est cette brûlures
c'est décharge électrique qui sont liées
à l'altération du sème nerveux des
douleurs extrêmement difficiles à
traiter avec les médicaments aujourd'hui
ça c'est un petit peu l'algorithme que
l'on a qui est prenait par les sociétés
savantes notamment la SFED TD pour
traiter la douleur neuropathique
ça c'est un bon exemple parce que on
voit que bon on propose les patchs de
lidocaïne l'AMM est seulement pour les
douleurs postériennes qui représente une
toute petite partie si vous prescrivez
ça aura même vous faites taper sur les
doigts latine elle est réservée aux
médecins de la douleur qui ont un
diplôme ou qui sont dans un dans un
médecin diplômé de la douleur ou bien
qu'ils sont dans une structure douleur
bon c'est beaucoup plus facile
aujourd'hui de prescrire de la morphine
que de la tens qui ne présente aucun
risque peut-être parfois une allergie
cutanée ensuite en deuxième ligne pour
cette douleur neuropathique focale on
n'allait pas de piment bon ça c'est une
avancée mais c'est possible uniquement
en HDJ alors parfois avec des acrobaties
de tarification ensuite en deuxième
ligne on a la toxine botulique c'est à
dire les injections de toxines botulique
dans les zones
concernées par les douleurs
neuropathiques aujourd'hui l'AMM
concerne seulement la migraine donc si
vous êtes en train de traiter de la
toxine par toxine botwique des douleurs
neuropathiques vous êtes hors des clous
pourtant c'est dans le recommandations
des sociétés savantes
les RTS bon il y a pas de facturation
alors que elle représente pour ainsi
dire aucun effet indésirable ni aucun
risque peut-être parfois une épilepsie
dans un cas sur 1000
la stimulation médullaire je vous l'ai
dit on a un accès une pénétration de
cette thérapie dans d'autres pays et 3 à
4 fois inférieur à des pays limitrophes
et qu'est-ce qu'on a en fait on a en
bonne place le tramadol dont on connaît
de plus en plus les problèmes de mes
usages
et les opioïdes qui peuvent qui sont qui
sont prescrits très facilement en
attendant d'avoir une place dans les
centres de la de la douleur chronique
donc
et le Lyrica à l'imprégabaline que j'ai
je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure qui est
pas plus efficace suivant certains
papiers qu'un placés beau et avec de
plus en plus de problèmes de mes usages
donc en définitive si on veut on
souhaite que les jeunes restent que les
chutes que les jeunes viennent et que
les vieux médecins de la douleur comme
moi reste il va il va falloir
revaloriser les actes intellectuels
et puis toute cette prise en charge non
médicamenteuse qui est dans le flou et
puis aussi évaluer les résultats et pour
ça on a des outils numériques de plus en
plus de plus en plus performant
et des soins rapides des soins adaptés
chez les patients douloureux chroniques
sont le meilleur garant d'une reprise
d'activité professionnelle et donc des
bénéfices qui peuvent couvrir ces coups
de d'augmentation des honoraires alors
je vais conclure par ce sms là d'une
collègue d'une collègue que j'ai bon
c'est un peu pour incarner mon propos
que j'ai reçu il y a une dizaine de
jours
bon qui s'apprête comme d'autres un
petit peu à mettre la clé sous la porte
alors parmi ceux qui s'intéressent à la
douleur chronique il y a les
anesthésistes il faut savoir qu'un
anesthésiste qui s'intéresse à la
douleur chronique il voit ses revenus
divisés par deux ou trois par rapport à
l'anesthésie
traditionnelle qui va qui va faire en
salle d'opération donc c'est pas du tout
incitatif pourtant je suis convaincu que
c'est un métier qui est enfin moi c'est
un métier qui me comble parce que c'est
extrêmement gratifiant quand on se
dirige vers la médecine c'est pour pour
soulager la souffrance et là nulle part
mieux qu'ici en fait on peut soulager
son son prochain et malheureusement
c'est une spécialité l'algologie
libérale qui va mourir avant même d'être
né parce que la les valorisations sont
pas du tout à la hauteur voilà merci
beaucoup de votre attention
merci alors
Laurent Burgoa Chantal de Seine
merci mesdames messieurs pour vos propos
moi j'aimerais connaître votre avis sur
la place que pourrait prendre le
cannabis médical dans la prise en charge
de la douleur en effet actuellement
l'Agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament
espérémente le cannabis à usage médical
dans les cinq indications thérapeutiques
visa à soulager certains patias de
diverses douleurs il s'agirait d'une
solution
thérapeutique qui demain en cas de
généralisation apporterait une nouvelle
offre pour une prise en charge médicale
de la douleur pour autant
si cette généralisation est en bonne
voie les conditions ne sa mise en oeuvre
qui devraient intervenir normalement on
va dire au printemps 2024 sont
particulièrement floues pour de nombreux
acteurs je pense notamment pour les
laboratoires qui font ces recherches là
puisque les ministères les
administrations ne communiquent pas à ce
jour leur intention sur ce sujet donc
j'aimerais bien connaître si vous le
souhaitez votre avis sur ce sujet là
on va prendre toutes les questions
Chantal de Seine merci madame la
Présidente merci pour vos exposés
respectifs la douleur est une notion
très subjective et quand un médecin vous
dit sur une échelle de douleur comment
vous appréciez votre douleur est-ce que
vous médecin vous avez des outils pour
apprécier le degré de douleur alors j'ai
bien entendu dans vos propos
l'importance du contexte social
économique des modes de vie etc et puis
je rejoins la question de mon collègue
Laurent Burgoa parce que je voulais vous
interroger aussi sur le cannabis
thérapeutique dont on parle beaucoup
actuellement merci
je rappelle que c'est une
expérimentation qui voit la faisabilité
c'est à dire comment on prescrit comment
on délivre et comment les patients vont
aller avec
c'est pas une expérimentation comme un
temps sur un médicament avec un contrôle
placebo d'accord ça c'est important de
le comprendre puisque pour nous on est
un petit peu pris on dirait entre deux
feux entre le sur la science qui
nécessite d'avoir des preuves factuelles
et que là on doit avoir contre un
placebo pour savoir si l'efficacité est
là ou pas et là une expérimentation qui
regarde un peu
non parce que comme on est en visio il
vaut mieux alors
je vais continuer ici donc il nous
manque en fait cette contrôle pour dire
pour l'efficacité et c'est quelque chose
qui vont un petit peu dédommager qui a
été décrits d'ailleurs par la l'Académie
nationale de médecine et qui nous met un
petit peu mal à l'aise
par contre
40% des patients semblent soulager sur
les premiers résultats de cette
expérimentation qu'est-ce qu'on peut
maintenant il faut être prudent dans ce
résultat puisque comme il n'y a pas de
Placebo le fait le seul fait de
s'occuper de ses patients voilà il faut
le prendre avec beaucoup de précautions
c'est résultats voilà je pense que le
problème du cannabis c'était un problème
qui dépasse la problématique médicale il
y a beaucoup d'attentes des patients ce
n'est pas la panacée d'après les toutes
les études qui a eu précédemment il y a
à peu près impatience sur 11 sur 12 qui
est soulagée alors c'est très très peu
quand on regarde par rapport à toutes
les techniques qu'on vient de vous
montrer de neuromodulations qui est
impatient sur deux de soulager un sur 7
pour les traitements médicamenteux mais
peut-être que pour le 13e
sur la suite je peux pas vous dire parce
que je détiens pas toutes les
pour compléter ce que dit Valéria ma
crainte pour être un peu plus cash c'est
que la le cannabis thérapeutique que la
demande de cannabis thérapeutique
puisse en fait mettre le trouble dans la
douleur chronique parce que ça rejoint
en fait la question tout à l'heure
comment on prouve la douleur en fait la
douleur est ce prouve pas la douleur et
s'éprouve donc comment on va faire la
part à un moment où le cannabis
thérapeutique va rejoindre les armoires
pharmacey comme la morphine parce qu'il
y a le riz parce que les l'épidémie de
de morphine on peut aussi imaginer une
épidémie de par le cannabis parce qu'il
y a aussi un potentiel addictif qu'il
faut pas négliger ça peut causer aussi
le trouble chez le praticien est-ce que
la demande de cannabis est-ce qu'elle
est elle est justifiée à ce que la
douleur est bien et bien sincère ça ça
peut ça peut poser un problème tout cela
pour un effet aujourd'hui qui est
discutable le NNT dont on en a parlé il
est de 13
voir il y a même des études des
méta-analyses qui montrent qu'il y a pas
de différence avec le placebo moi j'ai
coutume de comparer ça à
20 c'est un petit antalgique c'est un
petit hypnotique et c'est un petit
anxiolytique tous les deux c'est des
drogues d'origine végétale
peut-être pour compléter la question sur
l'évaluation de la douleur j'aimerais
insister et reprendre la différence
entre douleur aiguë et douleurs
chroniques puisque c'est une confusion
que beaucoup de personnes ont déjà des
politiciens mais également des médecins
et même les patients la douleur aiguë
c'est un symptôme un symptôme de quelque
chose qui va pas une alarme qui se met
en place et là il faut aller chercher
qu'est-ce qui se passe il appendicite
une inflammation on va traiter et elle
va partir c'est comme ça qu'on a été
formé en médecine c'est comme ça que son
compte les médecins sont formés et puis
que la population entend la douleur il y
a quelque chose qui va pas il faut
traiter et ça va partir la douleur
chronique c'est pas ça c'est cette
alarme qui reste allumée parfois on la
guéri parfois on trouve pas pourquoi on
a mal et la douleur la l'alarme va
rester elle va dysfonctionner et elle va
donc entraîner peu à peu des troubles du
sommeil de l'humeur des troubles de
relations arrêtez le travail etc et donc
ça c'est qui ont fait la maladie et là
on ne peut pas attendre un soulagement
total mais un accompagnement on peut
attendre une étiquette une diminution du
retentissement de cette douleur on peut
pas attendre un soulagement total ou
c'est extrêmement rare et donc déjà il
faut bien comprendre la différence parce
que quand on parle de douleur aiguë
quand les médecins parlent de douleurs
aiguë tout le monde peut traiter la
douleur régulière la douleur chronique
c'est une maladie il faut une expertise
et beaucoup de temps pour la prendre en
charge et des techniques sophistiquées
comme on vient de parler aujourd'hui
et donc pour compléter les propos de
Valérian Martinez il existe des
questionnaires spécifiques en fonction
des typologies de douleurs chroniques
dont le plus connu ldn4 pour la douleur
neuropathique tout à fait et puis on
mesure dans une consultation mesure pas
seulement la douleur on va mesurer son
retentissement on a des questionnaires
qui vont évaluer l'anxiété le niveau
d'anxiété de dépression de
catastrophisme l'impact qu'on ces
douleurs et donc ça fait partie de
l'évaluation complète de la douleur
après bien sûr c'est l'écoute
bienveillantes du médecin qui qui va lui
également la douleur il y a pas que
l'intensité en douleur chronique bien
évidemment
un
exactes mais merci madame la Présidente
merci
Monsieur et mesdames pour vos exposés
moi je voulais vous questionner sur la
fin de vie est-ce que vous pensez que la
sédation profonde est continue est
adaptée pour soulager la douleur dans
toutes les situations et ce que vous
travaillez avec les équipes de soins
palliatifs justement sur les techniques
d'octobre dont vous avez parlé qui
pourrait aider à soulager la douleur de
ces personnes qui
qui justement traîne des maladies
incurables et qui ont parfois du mal à
être soulagés et qu'elle est voilà quel
est votre approche justement de cette
période là pour aider à soulager les
malades merci Florence la charade
merci madame la Présidente
la migraine concerne je crois une
personne sur cinq c'est moi
vous
le migraineux il a des tas d'astuces
pour éviter de déclencher peut-être la
migraine et puis il peut surconsommer ou
pas des produits enfin
finalement quand on est migraineur on
apprend à connaître sa maladie je me
demande si l'électrotimulation
fonctionne et si on peut envisager que
chaque passion puisse avoir son propre
électros voyez ce qui a des appareils
portatifs qu'on puisse mettre en
autoconsommation chez le chez le patient
et deuxièmement comme pédiatre je me
demandais si vous étiez penché sur la
douleur chronique de l'enfant par
exemple dans les polyarthrites enfin
dans les maladies rhumatismes ou autre
est-ce que vous êtes sollicité pour ce
type de pathologie
emiliane Pomerol moi j'aurais deux
questions et ensuite vous pourrez
répondre Émilienne pour me rendre oui
moi je voudrais insister peut-être sur
la formation des médecins vous êtes avec
raison que un médecin généraliste avec
une consultation qui est passée très
récemment à 26 euros 50 comment peut-il
avoir le temps de faire tout ce j'allais
dire questionnaire auquel on a toujours
enfin je dirais qu'on avait l'habitude
de faire mais qui est de plus en plus
difficile avec la pénurie de médecins
ils ont de plus en plus de patients à
prendre en charge et donc effectivement
tout tout ce contexte est difficile à
appréhender pour pour un généraliste et
on a très peu de centres vous l'avez
évoqué de douleurs chroniques enfin moi
je me souviens sur Toulouse
très peu fourni je crois qu'il y a un
centre enfin je suis même sûr un seul
centre
et donc comment aujourd'hui au niveau de
la formation déjà dans le cursus
universitaire normal je vais dire de
médecin généraliste on peut mieux
intégrer toutes ces données pour que les
médecins
qui sont en première ligne parce que
c'est quand même généraliste qui est en
première ligne puisse plus facilement
orientée alors si l'on fait des
structures effectivement il va falloir
quand même créer des structures mais
comment voyez vraiment la nécessité de
la formation du médecin généraliste
et moi avant que vous répondiez
j'avais une question est-ce que vous
êtes penché sur les douleurs de covidon
existe-t-il des douleurs de covidon et
si oui est-ce que vous êtes penché
dessus et
on voit la difficulté que l'on a dans
les nouvelles
façons de traiter la douleur ou des
l'autre jour j'ai rencontré des
d'ailleurs j'ai vu Marc l'évêque que
vous aviez fait un article sur ces
traitements du tremblement essentiel ou
de la maladie de Parkinson qui se fait
soit de façon médicamenteuse soit de
façon
façon profonde mais aussi maintenant en
effet avec des appareils que les gens
peuvent mettre qui leur diminuent
considérablement leur tremblements
cette difficulté qu'on les pouvoirs
publics à intégrer dans la nomenclature
ou dans la cotation des actes des
techniques nouvelles on l'a beaucoup
dans les médicaments innovants mais on
l'a dans les dispositifs innovants et
c'est un sujet sur lequel il va vraiment
falloir se pencher parce que derrière
certes un coup qui peut être celui de
nouvelles prises en charge il y a quand
même derrière des résultats en termes ne
financier qui sont considérables les
conséquences et c'est pour ça que
j'avais souhaité cette table ronde parce
que lorsqu'on s'était rencontré à
l'Institut sapiens ou aussi à la flare
d'ailleurs
ce coussent social de ce que sont les
douleurs chroniques avec des gens qui ne
travaillent plus
un coup personnel et sociétales qui
considérable donc il faut vraiment qu'on
comprenne cela en charge et cette
facilité du médicament
on l'a tous je veux dire on aime bien
avoir le médecin qui vous donne un
traitement et qui vous disent voilà vous
allez prendre ça puis ça ira beaucoup
mieux mais bon sur quelque chose d'aigu
ça peut aller mais c'est vrai quand on
voit des gens qu'on est traitements
longs courts de médicaments type
tramadol ou autre et avec des
conséquences très très importantes donc
ça c'est pas vous qui aurait la réponse
sur les les la réponse de
la puissance publique sur ce sujet mais
je pense que vraiment il faut vraiment
que
notre commission mais aussi en insiste
vraiment sur ce sujet dans les mois qui
viennent pour que qui est un peu une
modernisation des des nomenclatures et
on le voit sur les tests compagnons dans
l'accompagnement des tests pour le
traitement du cancer la même chose quoi
c'est très très long à bouger il y a une
inertie considérable ça fait son rapport
j'espère qu'il sera un aiguillon en ce
sens mais je pense que vraiment il y a
un sujet à faire voilà alors qui
commence à répondre aux questions
migraines il y avait migraine
covidon fin de vie alors
je pense
sur la fin de vie il faut comprendre que
les structures de la douleur c'est pas
leur quotidien la fin de vie il y a la
moitié des structures douleurs en France
une heure actuellement 277 et la moitié
s'occupe de douleurs de cancer et de
douleur chronique et la fin de vie n'est
pas l'autre quotidien en tant que elle
s'est notre expertise en douleur par
contre peut aider à apporter des
solutions dans ces douleurs réfractaires
et je répète une des solutions c'est
l'accès à certaines de ces techniques
qui pourraient justement diminuer cette
demande de sédation profonde
l'intrateccale est une de ces solutions
mais une à d'autres il y a d'autres
techniques qui ont été recommandées en
2013 par des sociétés savantes ça peut
être par exemple ce qu'on a dit
la neurolyse de certains ganglions c'est
à dire endormir les nerfs qui vont dans
certaines régions et qui va me permettre
d'avoir de diminuer des douleurs et bien
sûr notre apport qu'on pourrait c'est
que on pose cette question est-ce que
les patients qui sont en fin de vie ont
pu avoir accès où on a pu leur proposer
ces techniques voilà ce qu'on peut
répondre en tant que
dans les structures douleurs avec notre
expertise et
oui vous dites que ça existe mais ce qui
est ont accès est-ce que vous connaissez
des structures de soins palliatifs qui
vous contactent et puis qui après
intègre finalement ces techniques dans
le soin qu'elles apportent au malade il
y a une c'est pas la même chose de dire
que les techniques existent et de dire
que les techniques sont appliquées donc
qu'est-ce que vous avez connaissance que
sont impliqués tout cela il faut de
l'organisation il faut il faut du monde
comme je l'ai dit actuellement il y a
150 000 patients qui meurent de cancer
tous les ans sur cela il y a 4500
patients qui ont des douleurs
réfractaires qui pourraient bénéficier
de ces techniques il y en a à peu près
300 pompes de ces pompes intra teckel
qui sont posées donc c'est impatient sur
10 donc il a 9 sur 10 qui ne bénéficient
pas parce qu'il nous arrive pas parce
qu'elles sont peu connues parce qu'il y
a pas les médecins sont pas assez formés
il y a 30 médecins qui posent
actuellement en France ces pompes c'est
largement insuffisant c'est pas des
choses très très compliquées à poser il
faut former continuer à les à les suivre
ces patients valoriser le suivi de ces
pompes peut-être que toi tu as des
chiffres très précis mais le suivi de
ses pompes il faut les patients pour
l'instant ils doivent revenir pour
remplir ces pompes à l'hôpital alors
qu'on pourrait l'organiser à domicile
qu'on pourrait suivre ces patients mais
il faut que ça soit valorisé
comptabilisé que les gens soient formés
donc toutes les thématiques qu'on a
qu'on a évoqué tout à l'heure
sachant que toutes les techniques
évoquées par Valéria Martinez sont bien
sûr recommandées dans les travaux de la
HS sur les antalgies rebelles enfin sur
la question que vous posez vraiment
parce qu'on a travaillé la Haute
Autorité de Santé en tout ce que j'ai
dit mais on a avant en 2018 on a
travaillé et en 2020 sur l'antalgie des
douleurs rebelles dans les indications
que dont vous parlez madame donc tout ça
c'est bien recommandé par les structures
les autorités de santé
donc c'est une question d'accès et de
mise en œuvre
c'est sûr que les douleurs de la de les
douleurs cancéreuses sont sont pas
suffisamment bien prises en charge il y
a toutes sortes de techniques
auxquelles les patients n'ont pas accès
je crois que du côté danger en fait on a
50 fois plus d'accès à la pompe
amorphine que par exemple à la
Pitié-Salpêtrière ou j'étais où il y a
une ou deux pompes à morphine qui sont
posées par an à l'époque où j'y étais
donc il y a une inégalité géographique
qui est très importante à cette
inégalité géographique s'ajoute aussi la
répartition en lit de soins soins
palliatifs qui est assez légal donc la
crainte en fait de voir
ce débat dans de la fin de vie c'est que
à un moment donné où on n'est pas en
mesure d'offrir un soulagement efficace
de la douleur qui est cette cette
solution de facilité faut bien le dire
de mettre fin à la vie alors qu'on
pourrait mettre fin aux souffrances
on est toujours dans le débat de ce
matin
[Musique]
sur la pédiatrie je peux rajouter c'est
un vrai problème la pédiatrie la
pédiatrie et la douleur en fait il y a
très peu de centre qui s'occupent de
douleurs chez l'enfant il y en a 15 qui
sont spécialisés en France il n'a pas
suffisamment il n'a pas un par région il
a beaucoup sur l'Île-de-France pas dans
toutes les régions et il y a eu un cri
d'alarme des pédiatres qui font de la
douleur récemment puisque vous savez que
le poste covid a entraîné beaucoup de
souffrance beaucoup de souffrance
psychiques beaucoup de souffrance
psychiques dans les familles et ça ça se
répercute chez les enfants et des
enfants qui vont pas bien et bien ils
ont mal ils ont mal au ventre ils ont
mal à la tête ils ont des migraines et
ils se présentent avec les les files
d'attente des enfants sont passés de
quelques semaines parce que c'est plus
petites dans les files d'attente des
soldats de Blanche enfants jusqu'à 6
mois sur l'Île-de-France donc il y a une
vraie inquiétude
très bien
et la migraine la migraine la
neomodulation effectivement peut
il y a une sorte de bandeau de
neuromulation qui s'appelle céphalique
et qui est commercialisé qui est
effectivement un appoint où on l'espoir
vient également et surtout là pour le
coup de la de la médication et des
Antilles corps antiségrp là aussi un
problème d'accès aujourd'hui assez
thérapie qui sont uniquement sur
réserves hospitalière donc ça c'est un
motif de de plainte des patients
migraineux l'accès à ces Antilles CGRP
qui sont pour le coup très efficace
merci beaucoup merci pour cette audition
pour toutes les pistes que vous nous
avez données
vous nous transmettez si vous avez des
documents à nos transmettre qu'on puisse
les mettre dans le dossier rapport de la
rapport de la HAS Marc l'évêque aussi
des publications ou des choses qui
pourraient corroborer tout ce que vous
nous avez dit et bien sûr les
propositions de la SFE TD c'est un vrai
sujet mais qui touche énormément de nos
concitoyens et car comme je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure des impacts considérables
que l'on a tendance un petit peu à
négliger il faut bien le dire et s'il
n'y avait que cela
mais merci pour vos échanges et de votre
écoute merci à vous à bientôt pour
l'invitation